I was packing furiously to catch an early morning Metro-liner to Washington D.C..
watching with one eye the political pundit panel on The Today Show when I heard it.
Al Gore is so boring his Secret Service code name is Al Gore.
I jump for a pen and paper to write down every syllable of this killer line beforeI forgot it.
Because I was on my way to Washington D.C., to the White House to write a funny speech.
for Vice President Al Gore.
This was March of 1993 and I was now on my fifth consecutive year of career crisis.
My career took a wrong turn right out of the gate.  Right out of college I joined the Dukakis
campaign. [laughter]
But in some ways it was the best job I ever had because I was 22 years old and I knew what I
wanted more than anything else in the world. I wanted to write jokes for a Democratic president of
the United States. [laughter]
It's a weird dream, but it was mine, and America's a great
country. [laughter] And, uh, uh, so, and before
the campaign was over I actually attained, I became the go-to guy in the
campaign to write the jokes if I knew ?if?. And that's how it became, I earned my moniker, 'The guy who
made Mike Dukakis so funny'. [laughter]
In
In fact to this day when the Dukakis campaign [is] dismissed as a joke
I [laughter],
I get all tingly. [laughter] But I never did get to write jokes for
President Mike Dukakis and after the campaign I went on to another line of work that didn't require anyone to get
two hundred seventy electoral votes. I went into advertising. And it turned out I had a real
talent for advertising. More specifically, I had a talent for getting jobs in agencies just
about to lose their biggest account.
So in four years I went through four jobs, I was in between
jobs in 1992 when something really weird happened. A Democrat got elected.
president of the United States.  You may remember Bill Clinton.
And I called my friends from Dukakis campaign, now honchos in the White House, and I started pitching myself as the
guy who should be writing President Clinton's jokes for his annual series of humorous speeches to
the White House Correspondents' Dinner and the
like, and they thought that was pretty audacious for an unemployed copywriter who
only had Mike Dukakis, uh, to his credit. So we struck up a bargain.
He said, "Listen. Al Gore has a speech coming up to the Gridiron Club. Why don't you
work with him and if that works out. We'll talk about moving up the
constitutional organisational
chart." [laughter] So as I'm sitting on this Metroliner
to Washington D.C. the stakes could not have been higher. And I am staring at
this joke,
Like it's a code that needs to be cracked. Like in these 16 syllables is this.
E = MC
Square. Of a, of a joke. That I needed to understand on a
sub atomic level. So I could unleash its power on behalf -and make a
speech as funny as that one joke. So for those next three hours that train was like a mobile
humor lab where I'm studying this joke. And it was around
Wilmington, Delaware where I had a breakthrough, I
realized jokes with the word Al Gore in them were funnier. [laughter]
There's just something intrinsically funny about the name Al Gore.
And then I hypothesized that if Al Gore said the name Al Gore it would
be exponentially
funnier. [laughter] And from there I
extrapolated that if Al Gore said the joke "Al Gore is so boring a Secret Service
"Al Gore is so boring, his Secret Service code name is Al Gore,"
Al Gore would be saying the name Al Gore not once but twice
and my head began to spin at the very possibilities of it.
So by the time this train pulled into Union Station I had an idea for this speech and I'm very excited.
And I get out of the train, I jump into a cab and I say the most aggrandizing things you can ever
hear yourself say to a cab driver, "To the White House!" [laughter]
And I dropped off at the West Wing gate and I walk in and I announce myself and I'm
escorted to the vice president's office and there I meet Lorraine another Dukai'ed done good.
And she, we sit down, talk about the speech and I tell about this idea I have for a speech,
that Al Gore should tell his favorite Al Gore jokes. And she says,
"Like what?"
Like, "Al Gore is so boring, his Secret Service code name is Al Gore!"
Gore!"
Lorraine falls off her chair with laughter. I couldn't imagine she hadn't heard the joke.  It was on The
Today Show. So many people come running into the office, 7 or 8 people. She repeats the joke,
more l-loud raucous laughter.
And in just as fast as that,
I was the owner of that joke. I wrote that joke.  And I couldn't, didn't have the moment, there wasn't a moment to say
uh, I, I didn't write that joke I just told you the joke and everyone dispersed and just as quick as that I
was the genius who wrote that joke.
Now I'm off, sent off to an office to write the speech
that has to go along with this joke. And in there for the next 72 hours I'm holed up in a room.
Thinking about the speech it would, would be kind of the proper setting for this crown jewel of a
joke and it's a whole speech, it's not just one joke. It's many premises. But it was, it took its
cue from the joke because the speech was kind of predicated and
executed in a kind of a third-person way. Where Al Gore would go fearlessly
at the idea of him being stiff and boring.
So on Friday morning, I'm escorted by Lorraine to the West Wing to meet
with the Vice President. He's standing outside his office waiting for me.
He says, "Welcome to the Square Office of the Vice President." [laughter]
It was, you know, kind of a prepared joke but I appreciated just the same and we walk in, and on his
wall I see the picture, a famous picture of the earth as big blue marble.
And I noticed it because my freshman year roommate had the same picture up and I immediately had a
flashback. And he says, uh, uh, "You like that photograph?
I took it
myself." [laughter] You know. Just one of the prepared jokes. But, look, I, I
was impressed with the guy because of the
two of us, him the second ranking constitutional officer in the United States, and me an itinerant wise
ass of the two of us, He was the one who was huffing it to show me how funny he was.
[laughter] That's
when I knew I liked Al Gore. [laughter] So he says, uh, so we sit down for this meeting, he says, uh,
"Do you have any ideas for an opening bit?"
Now I was actually taken aback because bit is kind of comedy parlance.
And I said, just to show I shot back I just said, uh, a joke, I want to see if I can make him laugh, I said,
"Yeah, yeah, we're going to, uh, uh, put you out in a hand truck and wheel you out to the podium."
He says, "I love
it!" [laughter]
Now I'm struggling to catch up to him because I just said as a joke to see if I can make him laugh,
he actually beat me to the actual idea. And I'm struggling to catch up, I'm like, "Oh, yes, wait a second,
let's actually put Al Gore in a hand truck and roll him out to the podium and, uh,
yes, this is brilliant! Good God I am a genius!"
[laughter]
So now we sit down to go over the speech and, uh, you know, explain, uh, the premise of the speech and then
we get to the section where he tells his favorite Al Gore jokes. And the beauty of it
is, the premise, he's just repeating jokes, he doesn't need to know if they
were original or not, they're just jokes that are his favorite jokes. The bit begins with, uh, "By
now I've heard them all.
Al Gore is so stiff that racks buy their suits off of
him." [laughter] OK...Thank you.
"Al Gore is an inspiration to the millions of Americans who suffer from Dutch elms
disease." [laughter] And now I'm holding my breath because I know what joke is coming next.
And he reads it. "Al Gore is so boring-"
He can't get through the joke, he starts vibrating with laughter, so - [wheezing laugh]
He's laughing so hard. And I'm struggling to make sense of this because I was nine tenths sure.
he was gonna say, "Yeah, you know, people've been telling me the joke all week, coming up to me, because they saw it on the Today Show."
This guy had crisscrossed the country twice
Since that joke was on The Today Show and no one had brought it to his attention. And I'm trying to -
Struggling struggling struggling to figure out what I
- was it really on the Today Show? Did I just imagine hearing it on the
Today Show?
And if I did, isn't that the same thing as writing it? [laughter]
So
we go through - so this is the fevered pitch monologue that's going on through my head
he continues reading through the speech and he gets to the end of it.
And we read through it once more time- One more time and  he goes through it and picks out
his favorite joke. You'll never guess which!
Lorraine says, that's a great joke, isn't it?
He says "yes". He's looking through the speech
He says "These are all jokes you wrote?"
Well I'd gotten this far into the week without sinking to an explicitly stated lie.
I just let this assumption go uncorrected day after day after day.
And
was burdened by it.I wished it was not - I never intended to steal this joke. But I just never could
find the moment - the right moment - to give back the credit. I didn't know how to do it I was
stuck with this joke and it was weighing heavily on me. But now the vice president had given me
the perfect opportunity to come clean.
Except Lorraine was standing right there and I would've had to revealmyself to her as a weasel.
That's when I heard myself say
this. Mr Vice President, I'm just a ghost writer.
As far as I'm concerned You wrote these
jokes. [clapping]
Now I am not proud of what I said,
But even as those words left my lips. Their brilliance
stunned me.
Deploying false humility to let a false hood stand. Was at least as brilliant
as the joke I was in the process of
stealing. And just as a political maneuver. Was worthy of my
current surroundings, the West Wing of the White House.
"Good answer." Al Gore said. Al Gore did not know the half of it. The next night
Al Gore and I put on our white tie and tails and go to the Gridiron Club. Now I must explain
to you what this is - three hundred of the most important people you can fit into a room
in Washington. Supreme Court
Justices, the entire Cabinent, The Joint Chiefs of Staff. I mean just to give you
a sense of this room. Congressmen are checking coats at the Gridiron
Club. And Al Gore gets up to give a speech and you know from
the very moment he was rolled out on a hand truck - and two guys wearing a
U.P.S.
uniform and signed for by the Gridiron Club - set off the speech with
loud uproarious laughter that did not abate for
the next twenty minutes. And I will spare you the many glorious details
of one of the great nights of my life. Except to say this. On the next day the front page
of The Washington Post aisle section had this headline in big bold type.
AL GORE: BORE NO MORE! [applause]
You're very kind. If there was any disappointment at all to the speech was the fact that.
right after the speech vice president had to leave early, hop on Air Force Two to go to some
to a hemispheric
summit. Global warming if I had to guess.
So we never got that moment after the speech to kind of high five in and share and enjoy this
This celebration of our This joint
accomplishment of ours.
So I go back to New York the next day enjoying my trip on the Amtrak train. And
taking pleasure in the speech I had written on the way down.
And I get a phone call from Lorraine a few days later - he's back from his trip, he's going to be up in
New York and asked to see me. He's going to speaking and asked if I would come to the speech. So I
take time out of my schedule as an unemployed copywriter
to put on a suit and tie and go to the Essex House and I tell 'em my
name at the door and I'm escorted to a V.I.P. room where they're five hundred people going to hear him speak.
But there's a dozen or so people been invited to meet with him before he does and in this room are the local
dignitaries and celebrities in fact - by the bar - I see Richard Dreyfus.
And actually I'm very excited to see him because I had just seen the
movie What About Bob? which is hysterical, a revelation of humor. And
I was excited to talk to him about it. So I, you know, we're all peers here in the V.I.P. room so I sidled up
to the bar and introduce myself and start  asking about What
About Bob? Well you know I should have taken the cue, he was wearing his very serious, bookish,
thick glasses that says "you know, I'm a serious person here to talk to Vice President about serious things. He had no
time for me.
So I back away. A minute later the Vice president walks into the room.
And I see him coming, he's coming in my direction but I assume he wants to talk to Chuck Schumer
over here or, you know, Charles Wrangle over here. But no, he's coming right at me and.
I only have time - I have a glass of red wine in my right hand I switch it to my left hand so I
can you know give him a good- this is a long overdue celebration, I want to give him a good handshake.
I underestimated Al Gore's enthusiasm to see me, because he reaches down.
Picks me up gives me a flying bear hug.
Hey, Hey, My Real my legs go flying out like I'm a rag doll.
The wine in my hand spills all over the place
he pays it no-never-mind, in fact it was right then and there that a Secret Service guy dove in and took
the
stain. [laughter] That joke I did write!
So now we're going over the speech like it happened Five MINUTES AGO. He's telling me what it was
like to do. From the front of the room I'm telling him how loud the last word was in the back of the room. Were going through a line by line
that was it joked with it. That joke was at nine that joke was a ten.  We're going through it line by line.
Finally we get to the end of the speech and we're done congratulating ourselves and he said a quick hello to the other
people in the. V.I.P. room. And as we're all filing out
To go hear the speech he's there to give and the five hundred people are waiting patiently to hear.
Richard Dreyfus turns to me and says
"Tell me who you are
again". And I told him my name but not
what I was
thinking. What I was thinking was: I'm the guy who wrote the
speech that Al Gore knocked out of the
park. I'm the guy who's going to be writing humor speeches for the president of the
United States of America. For the next four to eight years.
Who am I? Who-am-I?
I'll tell you who I am.
I'm the guy who wrote the joke. Al Gore is so boring his Secret Service code name is
Al Gore! Thank you very much.
very much.